what up guys today i am going to be
reacting
to marriage is the worst decision a man
could make by mediocre tutorials and
reviews before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it go follow my
instagram it's just probably things
with a z not an ass at the end
z okay time to get active
today's video is entitled marriage is
the worst decision
a man could ever make now this comes
from youtube channel
make it common and they have the series
called bridge the gap where they got
three women on one side three dudes on
another side
and the facilitator says a statement
and if you agree with the statement you
stay in
the circle if you don't agree you leave
the circle
and then you come back in later to speak
about what the people
in the circle were speaking about kind
of like a jubilee type of a vibe
okay so we're gonna get in there we're
gonna get active without further ado
all right let's see who leaves wow
wow all of them left okay so that means
that all of them think that marriage
has a benefit it's gonna get interesting
let's get active
marriage does have benefits so i agree
with that um
it's interesting because i see all these
high value men on social media
um and i have no idea if they're capping
if they're telling the truth about the
type of money they make what they have
but i know on social media platforms
they have every incentive
to lie like actually um
but i know actual high value men in my
life and most of them
are married i i can't say if the guys
you know that do these i'm not saying
him in particular but just like
guys in the manosphere there was young
one girl towards the
end that looked like she was hesitating
all right so then they're going to come
back and discuss all right
so let's do have benefits for a man
say the reason why because um you share
your experiences you talk to someone
they're there for you physically they're
there for you emotionally um
i think that's equal for both men and
women i think that he just explained
two people in love that maybe cohabitate
what a part of that is benefits specific
to marriage that was the question
let's keep going men does benefit from
marriage because when a woman wears a
ring
people notice it it doesn't matter how
small it is they know that she's married
she is she is spoken for by her partner
it's very clear even when she's engaged
it's obvious
like you will notice you can see the
ring that's what it signifies
and that's really important all right so
the benefit of the man is that
she the spouse wears a ring to signify
that she's married
for real that's the benefit we're just
gonna sit over here and act like there's
not affairs that happen
where irrespective of a ring being
present on the finger
[ __ ] i know people do's
in and around my space that will only go
for women that has rings on their
fingers
why because some of them have rings on
their fingers and they
want opportunities that have a
lower likelihood of her getting attached
okay um no i mean i could see the case
for possibly taking the government out
of marriage so i guess it would depend
on like what the question is
um because you know there's marriage in
the church and then there's marriage
um as an institution like a government
as an institution and then there's
marriage like with the government um
and i mean i could see the case for why
you'd want to take the government out of
marriage
but i think in general um
having a promise to someone that you're
going to spend the rest of your life
with them like i think it's good to have
an extra layer of accountability
where if things are tough you can't just
leave
um because you know in a 20
30 40 50 let's say you even make it to a
60-year marriage
there's going to be times where you want
to go where
you're not happy and
i think that extra layer of
accountability on both sides is a good
thing
knowing that the affair more than likely
is going to be
strictly physical okay so they go for
those so
that's not a benefit either let's keep
it going
but that's not important
it's just knowing you're accountable
there's no you can't be
you can't be wishy-washy in what you're
doing
it's the real deal and people it's
accountable people respect it on a
different level they do
and i know the manosphere i know the
comment section is going to go crazy but
there is a difference between saying
that's my girlfriend and that's my wife
i'm sorry there's a difference and
anyone with any intuition or just
reasoning
skills knows that there's a difference
between that's my girlfriend and that's
my wife
a man needs you you stand by that yeah
you can be in a relationship but just
naturally
the majority oh you're married you you
write on
on a paper single you're still single
until he puts a ring on your finger
she okay that's an interesting point she
said
accountable now i'd argue it makes you
less accountable being married well why
is that
well i think that if you want to argue
the idea that it makes you
more accountable to with uh be in your
vow
and not to step out then sure go ahead
because it churn
turns it from single to marry on your
tax form or what have you
i get that but here's one of my biggest
things about marriage is that it
de-incentivizes
accountability it de-incentivizes what
it is
that because at the end of the day you
can argue and [ __ ] like that but you
have to still be in there or it is of
great financial
uh disservice to the breadwinner okay
so that's how people get married and all
of a sudden like this is this new
instagram
trend that's like before marriage after
marriage
and then the chick grew 50 pounds
because dating she couldn't do that and
expect to continue
to date okay so issues that need to be
cleaned up
people can just you know say well he's
going to be there at the end of the day
anyway
right so why do i need to be accountable
why do i need to concede within this
conversation
why do i need to submit be agreeable so
forth and so on so i'd
argue that the institute of marriages
marriage de-incentivizes
accountability because well and i i 100
agree with him um where there are girls
that let themselves go after they get
married and that's why it's really
important to vet your partner
but if the argument is there are flaws
in this institution let's just
throw the entire institution away that
just logically doesn't
make sense to me cause when you're in a
dating game it's cut throat out here you
gotta be the creme de la creme you gotta
be the best of the best
let's kick that one that's from uh my
mom always says it's still single
perspective
but for the man yeah it's not a massive
single team yeah but what's
the benefit no the benefit of your money
is that i think you feel like
i'm going to be a provider oh jesus
what if i don't the guys are like i
don't care but it's significant
the benefit of the man is to feel like
i'm going to be a provider
my dad says about this i'm curious i'll
see if he answers
this is the blue pill conditioning like
yeah is there some dudes that feel good
let's see
i don't know if he's gonna answer
providing for a young lady yeah sure i
get it but again
the marriage part can you be a provider
without the marriage it may not make
extreme financial sense
but can you do it without the provider
then yeah sure you you can definitely do
that
you know you provide for your kids
there's plenty of single fathers that
are providing
for their kids but not even in the same
household but that's a different
topic for a different conversation to
the world that this is
his does that benefit he's not in terms
of ownership but it's like he's
his partner the world can see that it's
a visual thing as well
he's a rich man he has money if he has
kids
he can take care of those kids he's
paying his child support he's having his
kids over whenever he needs his kids
over
why does he need to be married the only
reason why that's a great point um
i got a couple of friends who say the
same thing it's like at this point now
that they've had kids out of wedlock
they're like
yeah what do i need to be married for
like no this is why
feminism i think was really bad for
women
because it gave men all the benefits of
merit of
a wife without having a ring and i think
it's incredible
incredibly harder for women to get rings
partially because of the courts
and they don't favor men and so when i
say
um when i say like i am for
marriage i don't want you guys to
misconstrue that i don't understand that
it has flaws because it absolutely does
but at the end of the day i would make
the case that you can fix the
institution rather than throw the whole
thing away
what's the point it makes no sense i
already got one i got a component of my
legacy that is continuing
you know over there so there's
absolutely no rush at all in order to
get to
you know in a in a marriage right like
it makes no sense
so he brings up a good point what's
interesting is that the young brother
walked away so it sounds like he slo as
he actually had time to think about it
right andy as he said wait a minute but
how does this benefit
a man pay attention i've seen that
because you're supposed to really being
scientific
because it's only because of religion to
be honest it's a promise to gods
um yeah does a man benefit from that yes
he does if he is
part of his religion or whatever it is
it's that promise i think
apart from that it literally is just a
social
so i'm i'm gonna i would make the case
where the government should get out of
the business of marriage that should be
within your institution
i i i'm with that change my answer
i now agree with it because just
thinking about benefits
alone in terms of if if you take
if you take religion out of it if you
take culture out of it and i'm just
looking at the benefit to be honest
i don't think anyone benefits but you
don't benefit when you really deep it
people don't say
and okay there are a lot of good things
said about marriage but there are also a
lot of
horrible things because you're dealing
with another person
on in a way that's you can sometimes
hate the person you're in a marriage
with
so it changes your whole mystery things
marriage changes your whole mentality on
a relationship in my opinion
compared to when you're married when
you're not married because
that effect again and this is just me
what am i saying no i agree
[Laughter]
um it's it's more it's more yes it might
change your mentality
but will that affect your day-to-day and
does it
mentally no because it's a good question
it changes your mentality but
what does it benefit within your
mentality this is why these
conversations like this is so important
to happen
because of the shift that you see
happening with this young man right here
because a lot of people just take the
word marriage and make it
synonymous with the benefit of having a
partner the benefit of having a support
system
the benefit of having a uh young lady
uh in and around your space whose words
that you respect
right that support you yeah well also
sorry i just
had a thought i'm sorry mediocre i don't
know what his real name is but sorry
mediocre tutorials in review i gotta i
gotta interrupt you for a second
the highest quality of women like
i would this is just i'm thinking out
loud here but i would think that the
highest quality of women
um aren't going to accept just staying
at home in a long-term relationship
because obviously like the highest
quality of women it's going to be more
competitive to win them
so when they have the option between
option a doesn't believe in marriage
and option b does wants to marry them
a lot of a lot of girls are going to
pick the ring
and good times and bad times but the
question is
what does marriage have to do with any
of those things [ __ ] i look at my own
family as well and there's
a couple of men in my family that did
the homarus thing got divorced and now
they're living
an ltr with a partner and
are happy as [ __ ] so again i ask the
marriage [ __ ]
what's the benefit just keep going
because for me it's more
without that marriage i'm still who i am
no no no no no right you got to be who
you are
no no no and i know that and i know that
but i'm saying without it
i'm still that person right and i still
have a certain mentality no but you
might and i still have the benefits of
my life
you might have that sense of
accountability or responsibility when
you're you might not but you might
no it's it's it's expected if you are
married that's the thing
yeah you don't have to it's not like a
thing where one person may assume
it's expected when you're in a
relationship i think a man's in a
relationship
expectations assumptions all these
things these these words are just it's
just loose meaning when you're married
sorry it's there's no everybody has a
clear boundary
there's not a clear boundary when it's a
50 divorce rate
it's it's not like you know there's a 50
divorce rate right now currently
right like so you're taking this um
this construct the social construct
where there used to be a time period
where
the word divorce was shunned
shunned when it comes to marriage
shunned
right but if you ask the majority of
people today
okay of you you take 100 ladies you say
of you
will there be any reason ever for you to
get divorced
ever 90 to 95
of them would say yes for some reason
for some reason
right same thing with dudes for some
reason
right so the power of of what it meant
to be married i guess because it's less
coupled with religious doctrine values
okay because of that there's a lot more
people
that are taking the disney version of it
right
and the movie version of it and applying
it
to their situation around love
right which can be fleeting let's keep
going
you can still not be accountable in a
marriage though you know
it only benefits the man because i'm
trying to think of the question but it
only benefits the man if he wants to be
in that marriage yeah
i think that because it is really and
truly you're right
i mean i'm i get taking the government
out of marriage
i'm with you that makes sense to me but
there's a deeper there's a deeper level
of commitment
when you stand next to someone and
promise to be with them
for the rest of your life and really
picture and imagine the rest of your
life without
is that is it a perfect institution no
of course of course it's not a perfect
institution it's got a 50
divorce rate who could possibly say
that's a perfect institution
um and the question is why is there
about 50
divorce rate and that's that's a topic
for another day
but i think
that the government should just be out
of the business of marriage
and that's something that you do within
your church
and when it's done in the context of a
church i do think that it benefits
men and women it's just a certificate
and it's obviously as a christian it's a
it's a commitment to god
yes but i'm saying it only benefits him
he's only going to do the work
if he wants to be in that marriage as
she said people step out in marriages
people sometimes take off their rings
they go
and they don't have anything but it only
benefits the man if his mindset is set
on that woman i want to be with that
woman
for the rest of my life he feels like
this is what i've wanted to do i've done
i think that's the only benefit it's not
there's not really i can't really say
there's a benefit
and there's no no and that's a huge
benefit if he really does want to be in
it yeah he's a huge
he wants to be that's but a lot of the
time it's a woman that wants to be in
the marriage and the man
i think even worse just doing it and
there's then the conversation of finance
yeah and there's a benefit in that kind
of way i guess like whether i don't know
what maybe joint accounts or you can
really invest into maybe a home together
um no that's where islam differs and
says that
oh he's an islamic anything a woman
earned just her money yeah and amanda
doesn't have any right on that money
which she has
really like that yeah whatever the man
earns he has to provide using that money
for family
i like that unsubscribe
subscribe all right guys uh
there's other way a lot of other topics
that's down into this right here that
was only a component of
the 30 minute clip that they put on so
i'll leave a link to a description box
down below if you want to see
these people go over different topics
such as this women are selectively
independent
maybe i'll come back later in a
different episode and go over that one
cause
guys you're looking at the title of the
video okay um
i don't know i thought that was a cool
video i've just seen
i guess watching my parents um they got
married young
and they just built something so
incredibly cool and i think about this
all the time how incredibly cool it is
that my parents
got married when they were young um they
even had
like a mistake like they got pregnant
when my mom was 18
they gave up that kid for adoption and
still built a multi-million dollar
business
went to the half half a percent of
income
had 10 kids none of us are like drug
addicts or anything crazy
like we're all relatively successful
right i mean some more than others but
like i think all of my brothers will
probably make six figures
i guarantee it at some point
and i've i have a couple that already
are so
i don't know it's just cool to like see
that be built
and i don't think it would be the same
if my dad was like that's my girlfriend
not my wife
um but again i totally see the argument
and agree with the argument i'm taking
the government out of marriage so i hope
that clarifies
what i believe i don't know so let me
know in the comments if you agree or you
disagree don't forget to subscribe to
the channel bring the notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time